Panthers control
[Applause]
fires it's blocked that's got to be
broken stick
five seconds
three to two
last scramble here at the end guys
Bennett and Carlson down on the ice the
Chuck and tarantula who came out on the
Penalty Box
are involved as well if you're Matthew
can chop you
got to be awfully careful here
[Applause]
fans throwing water bottles on the ice
this is embarrassing right now
[Applause]
after you cut chuck had an unbelievable
opportunity with a couple of seconds
remaining in this game and I'm not sure
bean and Hill got a piece of that or not
Zach White Club breaks his stick now all
Hendrix will watch him in front of the
net two whites the Puck's gonna work
itself back to the front of the net he
has no stick and Chuck has it and he'll
stops that with his left hand
oh
maybe McNabb got a piece of it before it
got to the pad
[Music]
oh my goodness what a stop
at the end of game four and then all
heck Breaks Loose
he had a wrestling match in behind